foreign
[Music]
and today we are honored to have as our
guest
Lieutenant Colonel Mitch Utterback and
we're taking a different tact from here
from our normal SOG stories because this
is an opportunity for us to take a
unique look at suck history and the
history from the OSS that led to Special
Forces it's this founding and then later
into SOG and I'm going to turn over to
you Mitch you can start out with how you
and I met now over 20 years ago when you
were working with Colonel bank and his
family prior to us losing him and you
had your official function with 10th
group at that time and you were kind
enough to come out to our special forces
Association chapter 75 meetings and we
had a lot to learn from there and you've
been giving us information ever since we
appreciate that welcome today sir thanks
tilt thanks for having me good morning
indeed and I'm grateful to be here let
me uh let me
add some accuracy to what you just said
pretty please so why we paid a big bucks
yeah so I was a I was a captain in 19th
Special Forces out of Los Alamitos Alpha
Company fifth Battalion 19th group
I was Prior enlisted in 10th group but I
never I never want to pass over my 19th
group National Guard Special Forces
background indeed so I was a 19th group
guy when you and I met and I was living
in San Diego Drilling in Los Alamitos
and came to meet Colonel and Catherine
Bank through the Special Forces
Association
and that's a reason why I would
encourage any young guys listening to
this that our members of the regiment or
recently
ETS
to join the SFA it's not just a bunch of
old farts even though if you look around
you might think it is well I guess it is
I'm here with till
but the oldest fart I'm 60 myself but
it's a great way to connect with your
history of the special forces and
through my membership in the SF
Association I met tilt I met Colonel
bank I met Catherine bank and that began
a relationship with the bank family that
continued to this day
with their uh with their daughters
indeed I remember that one one time in
particular I think was either 99th or
his 100th birthday we gathered outside
he spoke to his troops I want to speak
to you and he spoke to us about living
and moving forward in life it was just
like oh my God yeah and you were there
for that so it was a great day I
remember every interaction with him I
remember his voice he had a voice kind
of like this I never agreed with the
Pentagon
indeed that's the way he talked and he
was a literally the founding father of
Special Forces a living hero and a
legend and somebody who we all have
taken as a mentor whose Life and Legacy
we we try to carry on and until you do
that and I'm endeavoring to do that also
and we do that courtesy of Jocko willing
who I failed to acknowledge in my
opening but we're here at Courtesy Jocko
willing Productions but thank you well
that's nice I'm indeed that's uh we're
grateful to grateful for the benefit of
him allowing us to be on the air indeed
so yeah in the late 1990s early 2000s I
volunteered to be the bank family
liaison to the active duty in most
mostly because of the standing
contingency plan for final honors to be
rendered to Colonel Bank of upon his
passing there was a plan written at Fort
Bragg that was to be executed by first
group out of Fort Lewis because they
were the West Coast active duty Special
Forces Group but I was the closest
closest SF officer to the bank family
albeit National Guard still I was the
liaison to the bank family and to first
group for whatever would happen indeed
we did in progress reviews every six
months of that plan I regularly visited
the bank family as with you and went to
the Christmas parties at their assisted
living facility Well Catherine was
independent living and the colonel was
Assisted Living
and anytime there was a function with
the banks we were there including the
colonel and Mrs Bank coming out to Camp
Pendleton to watch a company do some CQB
training right now that was a real big
deal
I was at work as a contractor at Naval
special Warfare command in April of 04
when I got the call from
one of the daughters that the colonel
had finally passed and immediately put
on my uniform and spent the next several
days conducting escort for Catherine and
casualty assistance officer duties for
the bank family that was a great honor
and you and I were very closely
connected at that time and and at that
event is where I met Major General
retired John K Singh lab and I remember
when he walked in to the little chapel
where we had some of the memorial going
on and
the the atmosphere changed it was it was
uh the entrance of an American living
legend and hero on I would almost say
respectfully on a level even that above
Colonel Bank absolutely I agree and uh
it was uh the room was electrified there
were Medal of Honor recipients there
like Roger Dalman yes there were saw
guys there like you and others and
everybody stopped when major generals
saying loud better I remember that well
I'll never forget it I remember it well
and I just had this quick opportunity to
introduce myself and explain who I was
and then make sure that Catherine had
that you know something to drink or a
comfortable place to sit indeed but that
was um that was when I met him but as a
little boy speaking of General Singh
loud but I read the newspaper two
newspapers growing up in Suburban
Detroit the Detroit news and the Detroit
Free Press every day and I remember
in the 70s mid 70s 77 reading in the
newspaper about President Carter
um being pissed off at this Major
General Singh laub who even as a young
as a teenager I'm reading thinking
sounds like General Singh loves on the
right side of this indeed he's just
saying don't pull the troops out of
Korea or the North's gonna invade again
and again and uh so I've had the
opportunity to visit General Singh lab
and tell him that I first came to learn
of him while reading the newspaper in 77
in Michigan
about the two-star general called to the
White House which I found out later was
for a
sort of a Jimmy Carter chiclet-toothed
ass chewing
and one thing in the General's book he
said that Carter never stopped smiling
while he was ostensibly chewing his ass
that must have been creepy indeed he
also in the book also said that I feel
like everybody he had he had just
actually gotten dressed you know he just
put on a suit coat right and everybody
in the White House was in polo shirts
and
it wasn't a very formal White House as
the general said back then indeed anyway
many stories about we're a man of his
stature truly indeed yeah yeah they
didn't understand it being peanut
farmers and all yep so so that's how you
and I connected and that's my my history
with the bank family I um I had the
privilege of staying close to Catherine
long after the Colonel's passing and uh
in even in 19th group we had to take our
annual language proficiency examinations
to continue to get your language ProPay
so my first SF language was German and
that's the one that stuck best my other
one was Arabic but wow I would uh as the
as the now the Battalion commander of
the former company that I used to be the
company and Oda commander and I would
travel back to Los Alamitos to visit my
troops on their drill and schedule my
annual language test then but I would
also
schedule lunch with Catherine Bank the
day before and told her Catherine I'm
I'm having my German language test
tomorrow it's that time of year again
okay then Mitch we will only speak
German for the rest of the day
and so we did so it was lunch at lunch
in German with Catherine Bank to
lubricate my brain to be prepared to go
into those language tests and and great
part thanks to her and that that
training that exercise indeed I did I
did well did well every year thanks to
Catherine indeed so and so with the
colonel bank that's he's our father for
special forces and that lineage of which
Jack is such a key player because he
performed OSF missions in both World War
II theaters there aren't many OSS men
that have that on their record that's
right that's right only
um it's documented only about a hundred
OSS Veterans of the European theater
volunteered for Duty in the China Burma
India theater CBI and Aaron Bank was one
of them
Jack singlaub was one of them and Bob
Kehoe about whom I spoke yesterday yes
he was also one of them and Aaron was
over 40 at that time Colonel Bank sure
and he's remembered by the judbergs that
I that I have spoke with as
the oldest guy going through training at
Milton Hall is that right keeping up he
was certainly the oldest OSS jedberg
trainer trainee and impressed Singh Lao
been impressed Bob Kehoe I've talked to
both of them
uh about their memories of Aaron bank
and it was
it made me think of Martin Sheen's line
in Apocalypse Now when he's reading the
dossier on Colonel Kurtz when they're in
the patrol boat riverine going up the
Nung River and uh Sheen has a line
something about
um
you know they must have been they must
have thought he was a far out old man
humping it through that course
because you know Colonel Kurtz was
supposedly much older you know going
through Airborne yeah NSF so uh so to
you know to paraphrase from popular
culture
uh Aaron Bank was considered a far out
old man going through jedberg training
at Milton Hall by guys in their early
20s sure like Lieutenant Singh laub and
um
Tech Sergeant Kehoe and you know there's
a couple of pictures of Colonel Bank
where he you could tell that man was in
shape he was what we would say uh ripped
you know for a for a small of stature
and I said yesterday that I'm in my talk
that Colonel Bank was what would be
considered today a personal trainer in
the 1930s for rich people in Europe he
called it a he was a physical culturist
that's an old-timey phrase for a
personal trainer or a guy who makes a
living by being fit and teaching other
people how to be fit so quite literally
he's he remains a role model of mine to
be an old guy like I said I'm 60 but I
don't want to be looked at as man which
was a great Beret sure has let himself
go to hell since she got out you know
got to keep doing it colonel bank is
looking down on us saying you guys
better stay in shape your Green Berets
you got a reputation uphold there you go
indeed so through Colonel Bank we move
forward into the Special Forces history
and of course during that time Jack also
had service with spec ops in the Korean
War which we know very little about but
that's also a part of that credential
gradual transition where we go from the
OSS that converts to become the CIA
there's a period of time where everybody
appeared to drop the ball then the CLA
gets activated again and we had the
Korean War where Jack served with Valor
there against the calmness again yeah
hey well Mitch uh let me just ask you a
question about the OSS Special
Operations Branch that training that
they had during World War II that I
never realized continuing forward until
I heard your speech yesterday could you
fill us in a little bit more in that
lineage because that's one of the many
clandestine aspects here that are
fascinating well thanks yeah not in only
a few years ago did I really dedicate
myself to learning more about my OSS
World War II lineage
uh I also mentioned yesterday that all
of our history in the United States is
subject to redirection or redovision
correction or revision yeah unless we
pay attention to it and study it and and
capture it and pass it on correctly so
as I studied uh every book that I could
about the oss the Special Operations
Branch of the OSS specifically The Judd
Burks and the operational groups and
talking to guys like Bob Kehoe and Jack
singlaub at the time the last two
surviving jeds now it's just Jackson
love right I um I as I read and talked
to Bob and the general I realized that
the training that they went through uh
wasn't never got Dusty or Rusty and by
the time I went through that Army
special forces training 40 years later
it was this much of it was the same yeah
much of it was the same and as we know
in the military uh people were all lazy
and if there's a class that's already
been written I'm not going to rewrite it
I might retype it yeah and put my
signature on it at the bottom of the
training schedule but if somebody has
already figured out that the wheel is
round I ain't gonna add 361 degrees to
it it's still 360 degrees so yeah so my
study of our OSS history has shown me
that the training that they went through
Stateside at the Congressional Country
Club in DC
area B the Catoctin Mountain training
area which became Camp David in Maryland
training that they went through in
Catalina Island or at Camp X in Ontario
Canada even and also at Milton hall and
then some of the long humps they did
in the northern part of the UK
was just like that's what guys got the
idea yeah you know that's where some of
our long-range land nav came from
Special Operations training which was
conducted at Mott Lake at Fort Bragg was
as I went through it in February of 85 I
didn't know that I was going through the
exact same kind of training that bank
and sing Lao Ben Kehoe had gone through
when it came to stalking a century on
guard Duty and then sneaking up on him
with a knife and taking him out silently
and then Land Navigation land nav oh my
gosh you know the land nav that you and
I went to will tilt the land nav that
was being taught in the 1980s was a
direct Direct Direct
descendant of
SOG land nav land nav in Vietnam yeah
when it was it was too thick to you know
get a bearing on a distant Point sure so
it was just uh looking at your you know
getting the bearing on your compass
you're in my case you go to the
Vietnamese on a team and say here get me
here this is our map yeah yeah you had
your uh your Vietnamese version of a of
a global positioning satellite there we
go a human positioning system but uh so
yeah SF land nav training in the early
80s was directly related and many of
many of our Cadre in the early 80s were
guys that you had served with sure so or
they were you know they were like the
first sergeants of the training
companies and uh some younger guys were
doing it but uh you know I learned
to follow a compass Azimuth and do a
pace count and always know where you're
where you're at
um
and that that came from the long humps
that they did in you know Scotland and
Ireland to prepare them for long-range
movement and we know the OSS in World
War II did some long-range movements
when they got blown out of their blown
out of their gorilla base just like what
happens in Robin's age nowadays
indeed yeah so to answer your question
and Robin sage just for a record is the
final training phase for Special Forces
today that's correct and that's been
there ever since the Special Forces was
formed back in the early 60s yeah I work
in Robin sage as a gorilla Chief you
know you're well spoken yeah I'm a
gorilla Chief so I live it still and
I've heard Cadre say that uh it's been
around for at least 53 years it's been
named different things but
that final two weeks of the
qualification course is a 14-day
unconventional warfare formerly known as
guerrilla warfare exercise where we um
we
pinelanders are are um some American
Special Forces uh come to our country to
help us fight the occupation and so now
as I work as a guerrilla Chief as in
Robin sage we are doing the same things
that the OSS taught the French Maki to
do in World War II uh patrolling
techniques Land Navigation how to use
weapons how to conduct an ambush how to
set up a drop zone for a resupply how to
blow up a rail line the exact same
points with trains on them yeah indeed
same stuff so uh that I would say Robin
sage is probably the most visual
reminder that the program of instruction
in them for the modern Army Special
Forces soldiers
can be directly traced back to training
of the OSS specifically the jedbergs and
the 15-man operational groups so maybe
with that we could lead into
the early 60s when Vietnam is unfolding
American involvement is more is
escalating in the very early 60s the CIA
was running covert operations from their
own way and then in 1964 a SOG was
formed and then maybe go into that
the that transition there when it
becomes SOG and who Chief SOG was for
more than two years from 1966 until
August 1968. well that's the the country
chose well when Colonel John K singlaub
was asked to lead because
there was I would argue there was no
field grade officer
with his credentials to lead a unit
that I guess if you looked at SOG and
who they drew from and who they were
working with and what their mission was
there was no dart board to throw at and
pick a name there was one guy it was
John K singlao before his
his OSS
service in World War II in the European
in France and in China
his
before the term sheep dipped was around
you know he was he stayed in China for a
couple of years paying attention to how
the Communists and the nationalists were
uh which way it was going to go
uh it's specifically in Manchuria sure
his service in the conventional army
during the Korean War at Outpost Harry
which is which is famous you know that
that was also important that uh Colonel
singlaub had conventional Army
background in history and had been to
the command and general staff College
he had checked all the boxes for his
legitimacy and credibility in the eyes
of the conventional military like
General Westmoreland he wasn't
um he wasn't
one of you long-haired hippie Green
Berets yeah he was looked upon as a bona
fide highly respected very broadly
experienced conventional officer with
OSS background and CIA background and
had done many of the things already well
he had that he was about to ask you and
your teammates to go do indeed so much
to the point of leading from the front
that he rode the Fulton extraction
system before he asked you guys to do it
yeah it was nice 50s at that point he
wrote it in 67 and as a colonel again
let me borrow what I said earlier about
Colonel bank and Martin Sheen from you
know uh colonel singlaub was some far
out old man riding that
Fulton extraction system at an age twice
the age of the guys that he was going to
ask to potentially ride it and default
and distraction was designed for
something to extract either key
prisoners or key personnel from an LZ
and the person on the ground would be in
a uniform with a hook that had a wire
extended up with a balloon and a C-130
would come in pick it up and literally
the man on the ground would go from zero
to 130 miles an hour in one half of a
second or a pubic care and Jack said I'm
not going to have my men do it until I
tested yeah of course the little sidebar
today told the Air Force after you
picked me up take me over to South China
Sea do not go Inland they forgot they
took him Inland and they were shooting
at him as he was dangling from the C-130
you know I've seen that I've seen the
photos at his house and you know he's
wearing like one of those N3 Bravo
winter parkas yeah I think that's
nomenclature you know he's wearing
winter clothes on the ground in Vietnam
because it's going to be cold up there
before they haul him in and he uh
there's pictures of him inside the
aircraft covered in sweat but you can
see he's already debriefing the crew
chief on the thing and for people that
are listening if you uh if this sounds
any bit familiar uh if you've uh watched
the John Wayne movie The Green Berets
because James Bond won the early James
Bond movies had a Skype okay indeed so
the uh when when uh
when uh
Colonel Kirby John Wayne and his team
capture that NVA General and they pull
them out they pull them out by the
Fulton system indeed and so that's how
where you can see it see it in the movie
yeah so uh we're talking about a man
who's still alive at age 100 who has
always been pushing himself and the
limits of his ability to do the right
thing and now and I wouldn't really call
General singlaub a gray area operator
either he um he always stayed between
the lines but he he was racing so far
ahead of his commander's intent that
sometimes they had to say hey Jack
I'm gonna talk to you for a second yeah
he always got the job done God bless him
well and as chief saw from 66 until
August of 68 he fought for key things
behind behind the scenes such as getting
ch-43 helicopters for the king bees yeah
for them then A1 Sky reader support yep
which he uh had to go through the Air
Force and there's many a famous
background battle over assets that would
be there for the Recon teams in SOG on
the ground in Laos or Cambodia yep that
Jack was a critical player and so by the
time I get there may of 68 those assets
are in place we don't even realize the
battles that are going on behind the
scenes into service battles to get those
assets but he did it amen he he
understood you know in the korres
department of France during his team
James jedberg Mission it was him and his
two teammates you know with with his
French Maki but surrounded by Germans
the only air support flying over the
cares Department were German planes and
he was getting bombed by he-111s or
strafed by fw-190s so his experience in
this in the late summer of 1944 forever
stayed with him what it feels like when
you're on the ground deep Behind Enemy
Lines and you have none of your own air
support even though arguably we had air
superiority or over the luftwaffe event
but he was pretty far into France so I
would say knowing him and knowing his
history now speaking to you about when
he got you the air support and your
partner forces there our support that
stems from he had been at a point in his
life where he didn't have any and he
didn't want humanoids to not when you
and I've read his book I know when I
read his book hazardous Duty by John K
singla that part where he's on the
ground and getting strafed by the Nazis
on going oh my God Yep this is what it's
like to be on the wrong end of Tac Air
yeah because we always saw hey you know
we're cool here with our attack here but
I just can't imagine being strafed he's
been bombed by the twin-engine heinkel
111s and he's been strafed by the
vacavulf 190 fighter plane so he has
been on the receiving end of enemy air
power and didn't want you guys to be
without friendly friendlier power oh
yeah and again this is one of the little
sidewalks with Jack before he entered
the Army he's at UCLA he came up against
a communist era at UCLA oh yeah and then
even with the French underground and the
OSS he came up against the Russian
version of of the support of the French
and it's just like you could just see
important here reading that those
chapters and hazardous Duty was just
amazing yeah and that's something we had
to do um
you know during World War II with many
of those partisan groups were Communists
aligned and
fortunately France didn't go communist
but Yugoslavia did go communist in their
own brand
yeah indeed yeah there's probably still
Communists at UCLA so getting back you
know there's no question on my mind
about that
Professor yes so getting into the sog
side of things would be anything else in
the in that period from 66 to 68 because
I know that even when he left he stayed
in touch with the man who followed him
Steve Colonel Steve Kavanaugh because he
supported him who's cared about that
part and even though he had a new
command yeah there's Jack Still caring
about his prior command as well as his
new command as he moved forward in his
career yes
um
Colonel Singh lab experience leading SOG
he drew he was always comfortable in the
interagency environment because he had
it in his blood
you know if if there was a guy in uh
you know a guy in civilian clothes you
know
Colonel Singh lob spoke the same
language you know he was never going to
be too awed by a CIA officer coming to
talk to him I mean I've seen it myself
sometimes uh
Point regular soft as a little uh
bedazzled you know when there's a CIA
Mission coming down oh yeah sure but not
uh Colonel Sigma he um he'd been one of
them he was he had his Union card and
there was nothing that they could pull
and I'm sure that there were times when
he said
bad idea come come back to me when you
got more information before I ask my
boys to go do this indeed I'm sure that
that was the case and um something else
was important Westmoreland liked him you
know Westmoreland uh really appreciated
him and Miss Joan
has told me the General's wife
that uh
General Westmoreland after the war
had said to Joan singlaub
that whenever I had a
a difficult Mission I would ask that
young whippersnapper husband of yours
Colonel singla but I knew he could
always get the job done with SOG right
and just for the record I don't know if
that's westmoreland's voice or not no
but I liked it just for the record
General West morning was a supreme
commander for our U.S troops in Vietnam
for at least four or five years until I
believe generally Ames took over in
middle of 60 68.
so when you um when you're a
a CIA soft conventional guy like I said
Colonel single had all the bright creds
but uh to be so well accepted by your
conventional four-star you know highest
level Commander that I I see that as a
major accomplishment and A major benefit
to SOG also that um
the big battle space owner Westmoreland
had good relations with the sod
Commander Colonel Singh loud because one
of the benefits of a saw cat we had our
own Supply system set up with Cisco that
was in Okinawa I think and Jack helped
them to upgrade what they were doing
there and that's just another
sidebar to all this okay we got the guys
on the ground helped get the assets and
then the supplies we had any kind of
weapon we needed it came out of there
well as you know in in Army SF one of
our keep core beliefs and we know this
is we we need external support we need
conventional support to accomplish our
mission
you know it's one of the soft truths I
believe and
or is it one of the soft imperatives
somebody you'll know it's soft but it's
good moving forward but it's um we need
conventional support to accomplish what
we must and
Colonel singlaub with his good relations
with the big four star
um he he knew that in it and I wouldn't
be surprised if if this these things
that have been codified in our modern
soft today we can go straight back to
how Colonel singlao bransog and his
relationships with General Westmoreland
proved that you got to have good
relations and you need help from the
conventional forces indeed and that uh
you know again maybe we can break down a
little bit of unique training too from
the languages working with indigenous
personnel and that's all part of things
that go back to OSS lineage there that's
carried forward because today nobody
works as well on the ground with people
from any country because today we have
what over 90 different countries that SF
troops are involved in working in an
operational framework that's structure
that goes back to OSS to SOG days
yeah there's a it's not a coincidence
that modern Special Forces go to
language school as soon as they are
awarded their Green Berets so the end of
the pipeline is you make it through
Robin sage
about a week later 10 days you get you
graduate and you get your Beret and you
were just out there I believe in April
during one of those ceremonies and then
you do your language training and you
know before you go to Robin sage what
group you're going to and what your
language is going to be and no no young
man or woman enlists for SF training now
without the knowledge that you're going
to go to language school at the end of
this before you go to your Oda your your
special forces team
we'll take let's go back to 1943 let's
end at Crowder Missouri for the signal
school or Fort Polk Louisiana
or Fort Benning Georgia and I mentioned
these three Army posts because cam
Crowder was where Bob Kehoe heard the
call for volunteers for the OSS oh
that's right where Aaron Bank was at
Fort Polk Louisiana
and Lieutenant singlaub was at Fort
Benning Georgia Georgia
but uh all three of these men and all
all of our American OSS guys uh heard
some kind of loudspeaker announcement or
some kind of typed
um paper and type noticed in the company
message board
that said there will be a briefing for
uh
men interested in immediate overseas
assignment for hazardous Duty you must
be willing to volunteer for parachute
training if not already Airborne
qualified two years College preferred
and
competency or fluency or two years of
high school or above language training
in a European language so it was before
you knew you were getting into the OSS
in the middle of world war the
recruiting said we want you to have
language ability indeed and there is an
there is another
uh
genealogical Trace right back from today
yes to the uh the recruitment of our
guys for the OSS we wanted you to have
some language ability because that
proved that your brain was gonna your
brain and your tongue were going to be
able to work in a foreign language and
speak it and there was language training
um conducted I know at Milton Hall there
was a French language training conducted
for the Jets going into France and
you've seen this firsthand as a
commander in different commands under
your time in other countries where that
ability to have a language brings you so
close and a way to bond with indigenous
Personnel
you did that I had an interpreter but
for your side you're there speaking the
language yeah yeah tilt I've done it um
I went to DLI for German right and when
I was at E6
staff sergeant and was then recruited
for our our special Mission Unit in West
Berlin then called physical security
support element Berlin many people call
it debt a indeed and the great book by
Jim steskel Special Forces Berlin is a
great story to be to read about yes our
first major book on dead a so um I had
just come out of German language school
and I had I had some before that
so
being in West Berlin in a in a unit that
was there to conduct unconventional
warfare in the event that the balloon
went up
uh speak in German enabled me
to blend in because we were relaxed
grooming standards civilian clothes so
my German allowed me to not be tagged as
an American Soldier because there are
plenty of GIS running around West Berlin
but we distance ourselves from them and
didn't look like them and certainly
tried not to talk like them so not just
through foreign language where we are
able to better establish Rapport and
accomplish our missions in some units
that exists today still having that
foreign language ability allows you to
maybe not be taken as an American right
away so that you can move swim amongst
the fishes indeed and even one of the
little things they would teach you would
be when you eat you eat like the
Europeans do we're not like America we
cut the food with your knife and your
fork and then you put the fork down pick
it up with your right hand whereas as
Europeans
you just keep the fork there well guy
again that goes back to the OSS yes all
the way back to the OSS and there is a
movie a Hollywood movie that shows the
foreign culture competencies and how
they can go poorly for you
know the 1947 movie uh 13 Rue Madeleine
with James Cagney I remember he there's
a scene where uh one of the agents is
who has been told not to do it is using
his knife and fork the wrong way and he
is compromised and he's arrested by the
gestapo and he winds up dead and his
team has to go to ground and escape and
evade
a more modern version of this failure of
cultural competency is the scene in
Inglorious Bastards where Michael
Fassbender orders three glasses for
whiskey but he raises his three fingers
in the American and British style where
your thumb is held down and you put up
your the first three fingers and the
Gestapo officer busts him for it by
saying you you use the three wrong you
know in German three is your the one is
your thumb
so I when I saw that the movie theater I
said out loud oh crap that's not good
yeah because I'd literally been trained
in that that myself but those are the
little things that are so critical when
you're on the ground and each culture
has little idiosyncrasies that SF trains
for before to get underground so our uh
our OSS guys operating in Europe had had
that training um I received it myself in
in the 80s
and employed it lived it live
in in West Berlin and then nowadays as a
guerrilla Chief and Robin sage I'm
ensuring that cultural awareness and
cultural competency is is being imparted
into the students that come through my
lane and because we're a foreign country
I'm a pinelander I'm not an American so
I can say things to them just to show
them that hey that's not
that's not how it works here in Pineland
why are you being so American uh many
examples but there's something as simple
as
uh and I would I wouldn't say it to the
sergeant you know in Thailand I say it
to the captain indeed Captain
um while you're Soldier while your
sergeant was teaching a class why did he
have mouth tobacco in his mouth and why
was he spitting on the ground while he
was teaching us a class about the 240
machine gun here in Pineland we find
that highly offensive when you're
talking to us and you're spitting at our
feet are you meaning to offend us so I
can say this in character in role sure
and tell the team leader
hey uh you know Copenhagen isn't
appropriate when you're teaching a class
in a foreign country when you're
spitting yeah um so those are just
that's just one of the little things the
most surprising thing that I carry Mite
for Vietnam was this
never Pat a child on the head or another
person because we were taller a lot of
Vietnamese and As Americans Hey kid you
know you put your hand on them
particularly children and he said never
ever do it it's a little cultural thing
yeah right it's like just like what
you're saying yep good God yeah and
thank God I learned it because I you
know I was just like hey come on over
here we're on the same there's so many
things but we we in the Army Special
Forces we pride ourselves on trying to
be the best within our nation's military
at understanding a foreign culture and
the right things to do and the wrong
things to do and as you've mentioned
earlier speaking their language is so
important speaking it a little bit is
important especially important is to
know pay attention to the little nuances
of what they say
to show that hey I'm paying attention to
you guys and I'm respectful of your
culture case in point
when Iraqis sit down you know in a
comfortable chair
after uh you know a hard day of planning
operations
you know we Americans we sit down and we
might say something like oh man
yeah well when my experience in during
the Battle of Basra when we were
planning you know briefing and planning
the missions every night
the Iraqi officers would sit down and
they sit down and they just kind of say
to themselves
oh yeah
Allah oh God
and so I noticed that and I just started
doing it myself
just quietly you know I'd sit down that
I'm I'm the one American Special Forces
officer in a room with 20 Iraqi Special
Forces officers
counterterrorism service ice off guys
and I'd sit down oh yeah
and a couple days later you know Iraqi
General would come to me
major Mitch ice you talk like Iraqi you
are a rocky you are not American you are
lucky
and you expecting the Iraq at ease too a
little bit enough yes that in Arabic was
my other language yes and um I focus on
the operational aspects of it but also
like like I just mentioned the little
idiomatic expressions that that they say
and this is a demonstration of respect
for them and their language and their
culture and indeed their religion
because I just said Allah I said oh God
so this um this binds you closer brings
you bonds you and binds you the Three
B's closer to your counterparts and uh
you can you can accomplish so much more
when they look at you and think this guy
gets it man
we love him indeed you know he gets it
your history is so interesting to me
before we do it I like to close up with
any final thoughts on our favorite
living OSS General uh General Singh law
because we visit him for his 100th
birthday you were there and of course
the Special Operations associations vice
president Mike Taylor hand delivered
greetings yeah and uh you know just
talking to him
when you get in away from the people or
start talking about operations he locks
in yes to this day at 100 years old and
you just know he's with you on that he
sure is and uh so you've done more with
him along those lines any final thoughts
about that yeah sure please he's uh
he loves company
he loves to look at books that have
the history in it and it's sitting with
him that we have determined that not all
books are right you know he's
researchers right there are OSS history
books written now that aren't quite
right because
they
they just went along maybe with the
photo and thought that they knew what it
was
but uh one one important thing there's a
there's a photo in his own book yes and
there's a photo in some other books that
have a picture of him and it's often
captioned as him interrogating a German
prisoner team James
um but in that photo on the far left is
Adrian wise
who was the commander of jedberg Team
Frederick Bob kehoes Commander
and the photo with wise and sing loud
could have only been taken in October of
1944 when Adrian wise and Jack singlaub
re-infiltrated France to establish an
Intel Network and re-establish an Intel
Network in Brittany and the key word
there is re-infiltrated the second time
yeah most people don't know that Jack
senglau had two missions in France the
second one in the first week of October
only a week long but they he and Adrian
wise landed in a rubber rating craft in
the village of saint briac to reactivate
some Intel networks to keep dibs on the
30 000 Germans that were cut off in the
Brittany peninsula
just to know in case they were going to
move against the supply lines coming out
of the Normandy Beach heads
but he has pointed out to me in a in
books
that there's Adrian wise and this was in
October this isn't this caption is wrong
and general like I'm the only guy in the
world now everybody listening and
everybody that came to the presentation
yesterday now people know that hey let's
nitpick that photo in the future when we
see it in new books and hopefully we'll
get it right but he has shown me that uh
history is still in can still be
incorrect even when his life is so well
documented it can still be incorrect he
loves to look at books that have
pictures of OSS weapons and operations
or photos from Outpost Harry yeah he um
he loves to revisit photographically his
military service and he certainly
appreciates when an SF guy who owns a
business wants to send him some swag
whether it's protein powder from alpha
Elite Performance or some leather
patches from nailer Forge or artwork by
Frank Allen or a coin by John Joyce you
name it he likes getting that stuff he
loves to know that his service is
remembered appreciated and there are
guys still carrying on his Legacy
Fighting to make our country the best it
can be in our military likewise indeed
and George Sternberg who ran Recon with
the spike team Oregon
uh out of f will be won the later CCN
had the one of the Jason Hardy SOG wecon
books his pictures on the front page and
we gave Jack the copy of that and he
just sat there asking George questions
great and it was just like you said this
is one of those moments unfortunately
the history there was accurate we didn't
get any Jack Corrections
yeah but uh so I what I like to do is we
head down to home stretch of our
interview here and again thank you for
taking time for your schedule
um is to talk a little bit more about
your history because it's been
fascinating uh when you're in Iraq you
served there yeah and again you use your
SF skills trains
during the time on the ground then also
after you're out of the service you went
you went back for a second time yeah as
a journalist but first talk to First
about a little bit about your time there
because you made connections yeah that
were wonderful and then you went back
and reconnected take it from there sir
yeah thanks please in
070708 our national guard company was
activated in SF Los Alamitos right and
we were attached to First Battalion
fifth group at Fort Campbell right for
their Iraq deployment
so our company
fifth group wound up having one more
special forces company than they needed
of course
us we were the Tuskegee Airmen so um
National Guard guys we're going to
we're going to have the company
headquarters advise Hilla SWAT in Hilla
and we're going to take your other odas
and we're going to have them advise
different Iraqi Special Operations type
units and it turned out to be like the
coolest mission for an SF company I
believe during that time I cried
interject a second with a question I've
talked to some recent SF Iraq veterans
who said I believe it's that unit that
today is one of the best units in in
Iraq is that the same unit well Hillis
watt has been absorbed into a division
the emergency response division right
okay under the ministry of the Interior
but the Hilla SWAT guys have maintained
uh sort of Team integrity and they're a
cohort Battalion now so they are a
battalion of the emergency response
division
but they still love their hila SWAT
history and when I was with them
um many of these old guys from 07 and
Hilla recognize me and I recognized them
so it was a real homecoming I'll tell
you about how I got there in a second
sure
so when uh
0708 a519 is in Iraq under 1.5 first
Battalion fifth group
odas are in Baghdad advising combat
advising the Iraqi Commandos the
Emergency Response Unit they are running
training at area 4 for the
Iraq ice off the Iraqi Special
Operations forces and where would be
area 4 be in Iraq it's adjacent it's in
it's in Baghdad adjacent to Baghdad
International Airport area four was sort
of the Special Operations slice
terrain close to Baghdad International
Airport was that the old green zone no
green zone is different that was
Southwest the green zone is different
Southeast I mean yeah
so um when was it March March of 08 my
Battalion Commander said Mitch you guys
got Hilla SWAT where we wanted to be
down there we're going to let your Exo
Jesse
go ahead and run the show from there I
would need I need you to come up to
Baghdad and start advising the ice off
operations officer the uh
S3 and give us what that acronym is I
saw it as a Iraqi Special Operations
forces right they were a brigade's worth
of special you know Iraq's version of
armies their army Special Forces
so I became the advisor I was a major
and I became the advisor to Major Hider
Hyder al-abidi
so Hyder and so I had left General Abbas
who was the commander of Hilla SWAT I've
been his advisor for several months
and left him that was a sad parting but
we had a nice little party and we were
brothers
so I moved up to from Hilla to Baghdad
and met major Hyder and became his
advisor
advised him for a few months and we
in early March prime minister Maliki
needed to take his city of Basra back
from Iranian influence and muktada El
sadar's Jai shalmadi
so so Maliki decided to send his special
units
coincidentally all of them advised by
American Special Forces coincidentally
coincidentally three of the units that
went down uh
were advised by Army National Guard
Special Forces
yeah yeah one of those little gem facts
that we don't hear about right so the
ice off the Commandos specifically the
Commandos
the hill SWAT and the Emergency Response
Unit all went to Basra
all three with odas from a519 on the
California Army National Guard yeah
got a lot accomplished down there in
Basra that's where I learned to say when
I sat down and and really made sure that
my counterpart major Hider was the hero
of the battle in other words he did the
briefings you know I helped him with the
Intel helped him with Target selection
he made the decisions
I'll read the right one indeed
always the right decisions coached and
mentored by his counterpart
and made sure I elevated his stature
I saw General Abbas down there in Basra
leading hillswat
in the summer late in the mid-summer of
08 it was time to rotate back to the
States and I told Abbas and I told
heider Brothers I will return I promise
you I will will return whether in
uniform or not I am coming back you have
my promise and wasn't that
one of the bitter sidebars of spec ops
when it's that moment in time you got to
get on the plane and leave behind your
indigenous troops you've done it
yourself you know exactly how it feels
every uh every saw guy listening feels
that every every American that has had a
host a counter close counterpart that
had to say goodbye you feel that
Bittersweet parting but I was blessed in
2016 to be able to keep the promise
I had retired in 15
and I decided I was going to knock out a
master's in journalism at CU Boulder
and for my thesis my Master's thesis I
didn't want to do something lame and you
know like write a paper and take a few
pictures you're getting some education I
told my Prof I told my professors I had
an idea
and before I did it I I reached out
through cutouts because I wasn't in
direct contact with heider and Abbas
after I came back right because to have
a top secret clearance one of the
questions that the background
investigators ask you is do you have any
ongoing and continuous close personal
relationships with anybody any foreign
Nationals or some word something like
that yeah God forbid so I wanted to be
able to say yes so I mean I love these
guys but I didn't keep in touch with
them because I wanted to keep my TS
clearance
but when I got out
in 15 I started thinking about what I
wanted to do for my thesis in early in
reached out through some people and
established contact eventually directly
with General Abbas and now General Hyder
so I was shocked to see that they were
still alive after almost 10 years of
running and gunning for their country
that they had
the Iraqi military even though it was
poorly LED in 2014 and ran away from
Isis the Iraqi government was smart
enough to keep their special operations
units kind of in reserve not throw them
away like cannon fodder
but
in 2016 when the biggest city mosul
needed to be retaken
I was pleasantly very pleasantly
surprised to learn that General Abbas
leading the emergency response Division
and general heider leading the Iraqi
counterterrorism service had been
selected as the two ground force
commanders for the push into mosul
and I said to myself holy crap
a boss and Hider are the gfcs from mosul
my two brothers and I came I realized at
that moment that wait a second there's
no American
who has ever
advised both of these guys during the
same deployment
unless somebody's listening said well I
advised a boss and hide her too during
my deployment I haven't heard that yeah
so I I realized holy crap my access and
placement I think is going to be pretty
unique I've reached out to them and said
Brothers
I'd like to come join you in your fight
against Dosh for a couple of weeks at
the end of December early January I'm
working on a master's in journalism and
I would like to document your fight for
my Master's thesis
they replied back brother so good to
hear from you you can come to mosul you
can ride in the battle in my Humvee with
me that was just my general boss accent
indeed yeah so uh I told my professors
hey I have permission to go to mosul
Iraq embed with the Iraqi forces that
are right up against Isis and I'd like
to do my Master's thesis on the the
fight to liberate mosul from Isis
occupation by embedding with the Iraqi
units that are doing the fighting
um they had obviously never had a
student ask them that before I said by
the way I'm going anyway I've already
bought the plane tickets on Google
flights I've already reserved a hotel in
erbil on booking.com I'm going yeah okay
Mitch yeah so they were very supportive
you know once I I picked their three
right thesis advisors anyway guys that
already liked me yes I had taken classes
from
so I did my own pre-mission training
yeah before I went I got I went down to
Fort Carson and even as a vet I could
get vaccines if I needed them so I got
whatever shots that I needed I did some
combat casualty you know some first aid
train up
I took some more Arabic Iraqi Arabic
Refreshers refresher specific to the
trip that I was going to be taking I
collected some gear I practiced with
cameras I got there I got new body armor
I contacted other people that had been
there to ask for their tactics
techniques and procedures about getting
into the airport where to stay how to
get to mosul what kind of Kit you needed
all that stuff
literally did uh you know interviewed
people that had that I BBC guys you know
asked them like how did you do this Fox
News people how did you do it learned
what countries to not Transit through
which I had already done before I bought
my ticket my flight was from from Denver
to Frankfurt to Vienna to erbil because
I I avoided other countries where they
would ask you
hey why do you have body armor and a
helmet and cameras and a GPS and a SAT
phone
and uh why is there nothing on your
computer and why do you have a new
passport and why is there nothing on
your phone
indeed Mr you are using tradecraft
[Laughter]
to be a Savvy traveler I'm just being a
Savvy traveler and that's what I was
doing clean yeah so it worked out I uh
flew to erbil
and Link got up my hotel dropped a few
dropped all the right names at the
airport spoke all the right Arabic at
the airport spoke all the right Arabic
and dropped all the right names at the
hotel and worked the phones
and eventually by um within a week got
myself a ride straight to the
counterterrorism service safe house in
mosul and then rolled for two weeks with
the counterterrorism service and the
emergency response division
I broke my blog it's still online
hanging up online if you just Google
Mitch Utterback Moe's little blog you'll
see my Master's thesis from 2017 when I
put it there
I'm working on a book about the trip my
mission to mosul I got a publisher
already
but the book will be not just like a
first person adventure story but it's
it's kind of it's sort of a tutorial for
Freelancers that want to get to a denied
area and how to do it safely and come
back out the kind of prep that you need
but it's also going to be a a story of
the importance of
working within a culture establishing
close bonds showing respect and then how
with no maintenance on those
relationships over eight or nine years
in many parts of the world they're
waiting to be reactivated just because
of the good impression you made so long
ago welcomed back as brothers as you
guys from SOG when you return then you
could are able to link up or here and if
you go to Greensboro North Carolina and
you link up with your Mountain yard
teammates you know it's like you never
left indeed my my welcome back to Iraq
was um in great part based on the
relationships that I had respectfully
built eight or nine years earlier and
the book will talk about how important
that is so well you're also being very
modest here because you also have some
amazing footage and you did capture some
interviews with those key participants
that nobody else had no other journals
even came close to there weren't many
journalists doing without well there
wasn't even a journalist I mean no I
mean the most basic I was a college
student freelancer College nobody paid
me
um I was a college student working on my
Master's thesis okay on on the other
hand I was a retired Special Forces
Lieutenant Colonel who had been the
advisor to these commanders nine years
before that's amazing so I I had I was
like I wasn't
I was an atypical college student
or as they say at the University I was a
what's that fuzzy word they have for old
people that go back to school
non-traditional
it wasn't non-traditional student
oh an old guy that's going back to
college
oh fascinating and I've seen some of
that footage uh when you spoke to
chapter 78 a few years ago yeah it was
fascinating well I'll let you I'll let
you guys know in the book finally um
comes down so we'll come out back and
talk about it well could we definitely
come back and talk about some more
um with that thought we're heading down
to final Road here any final thoughts
either on the early side or the
follow-ups here for yourself and if not
we'll head out and wrap this thing up
yeah one thing that's important to me
that I would like people to know is our
old old veterans older than you older
than me
you know there are still World War II
veterans alive there are still Korean
War veterans alive there's a lot of
Vietnam veterans alive and guess what
older people still like making friends
but older people are losing friends
faster than they are making them people
are dying absolutely I want to encourage
anybody that sees a vet with a ball cap
that might say World War II veteran
Korean War veteran Vietnam veteran go up
to him or her
and not just say thank you for your
service
unless you know like that that's like
the PC phrase that everybody feels like
they have to say
but ask questions like
Hey sir
oh World War II did you serve in Europe
or did you serve in uh the Pacific
Theater right show a tiny bit of of
knowledge that's it
if it's Korea Hey sir
Korea huh man I I'd love to buy you a
coffee if you got a few minutes you know
I'd love to hear some something you
about what you've experienced if you
don't mind
I'm grateful for the country that we
live in now because of guys like you
if you see a Vietnam vet Hey sir
uh
I don't want to sound corny but I just
want to say welcome home I really
appreciate you guys and I'd love to buy
a coffee and I'd love to hear some you
know here are some of your experiences
if you don't mind we're a different
country now and we we honor and respect
respect and we appreciate what you did
so no we just sit around Vietnam at
night and we talked about which of all
the wars that we've been in which war
would be the one you would least want to
participate in it was unanimous Korea
The Chosen Reservoir you know my God
yeah you can oh yeah so that's what I
would like the listeners to take away
here at the end is
uh approach somebody with just a tiny
bit of uh conversation in you not just a
throwaway thank you for your service
you know indeed because they might be
they might be hard of hearing and they
might say I don't have a cervix I'm a
man
you know they said thank you for your
service not cervix I oh
indeed so anyway sorry to be a smart ass
but that's the way we uh
engage them
spend time with them if you live if they
live close by go visit you know assisted
living facilities and VA hospitals are
are full of people that would like
company indeed get off your ass and go
be part of the repayment plan that our
country still owes these veterans and
visit them in that case let me be the
first to welcome you to the old man
veterans Club sir thank you very much
and thank you for today thanks till as
we close here again we thank Jocko
willink productions for making all this
possible and um we also thank all our
service members today our five service
units of course now we have the space
for us so we have six military service
units we thank all those service members
border patrol First Responders law
enforcement that fight to keep our
country safe
we also want to thank the men and women
who have served in years past have come
home and men like yourself that served
Mitch was such a great honor for our
country we thank you and last but not
least we also remember and salute the
men and women who did not come home
of powmas
then we salute them and we close Orlando
always remembered never forgotten indeed
we thank Jocko uh willing productions
for this service thank you again until
next time get born stay oppressively
bear
amen